do you hope
that in the process of cryptocurrency
pushing power to the edges
to the people that we would be able to
alleviate some of the suffering in the
world
caused by centralized power and the
abuses of power yeah corruption all
those kinds of things
a hundred percent i made a very angry
video months ago
i make a i make angry videos i shouldn't
drink collects
you should drink more yeah i know right
it depends on who you ask i i made a
video a little while i said you know our
industry is an history of frustration it
exists because
we weren't the industry that charged 85
interest to the poorest people in the
world for loans we weren't the industry
that charged 15
to move money for for a maid sending
money home to mom in manila
uh you know we weren't the industry that
laundered hundreds of billions of
dollars of drug money and funded arms
dealers in africa and all these things
or
permitted oil for food to exist and so
forth uh
and the people who did these things
aren't in jail they're rich they're
billionaires they fly private jets
so our industry is the antidote to these
types of things
and we say guys we want a system that's
fair
that's it uh and we want everybody to be
treated equally
that doesn't mean it's everybody's gonna
win it doesn't mean that when you lose
you know somebody's gonna come on a
white horse and bail you out
you're gonna have winners and losers but
it's fair that's all we want that's all
we've ever wanted
there's no coincidence that bitcoin was
created right around the same time as
the 2008 financial crisis
it's not like these were just unrelated
events they're highly correlated to each
other
okay i'd say perhaps even causal go
figure
and everything we've done as an industry
from that moment
to today and beyond has been about that
that that endless relentless desire to
make things a little bit less corrupt a
little bit less nepotistic
and a bit more open and it
it's gotten so insane that they have
these things in wyoming called speedy
banks where your full reserve banks they
they have
100 of their balance sheet is is
accounted for they don't lend
and then you have the people in the
banking community saying well those are
a risk to banking
we were we're scared that these speedy
banks are going to default
it's like what world are you living in
you have fractional reserves sometimes
like two percent
assets on the ballot sheet and then
you're worried that the guys who
actually have a dollar for every dollar
they say they have are the ones that are
going to collapse
it's like the 1984 level double speak
when you see in the system and negative
interest rates and all these other
things and so
i absolutely believe the direction
course of this industry is
is to make things more honest and fair
and also by its very existence it
exposes
double standards hypocrisy and
corruption just the fact that it's there
because it's one thing to say that well
it just can't be because of the nature
of global finance there's no way to do
it otherwise
it's another thing to see it there as an
example
and say well that thing is doing it why
can't you guys be this way
that's why i'm so passionate about
africa because they don't like the
systems they have
and everybody's really young and they're
going to throw all the systems out in
the next 20 years and they're going to
replace them with something else
if we get this stuff into africa 1.2
billion people will be living in a
considerably better system than the rest
of the world
and then everybody else will look at
that and say why the hell are those guys
so rich
why are those guys making the money why
are those guys doing so well
and it's not satisfying here well that's
you know africa is just better
no one's gonna say that they're gonna
say okay yeah you know yeah it's
nepotism and corruption and you know
lack of transparency and these types of
things so i think
absolutely it has the potential to
improve the human condition
but humans have to get out of the way
humans have
ingrained in themselves selfishness and
it is a
desire to maximize the for themselves
and their family and not think in
systems
and so we have to evolve capitalism at
the same time
and what i mean by that is right now
you're trying to maximize the amount of
resources you get today what we need to
do is start thinking about how do we
create future versions of ourselves in
and create a resource for that time
period and then the name of the game is
to maximize
that or balance that with what you get
in the short term
and then suddenly you're saying to
yourself well if i'm doing things
that are good for me today but
compromising then i make less money
so so capitalism as an engine is okay
the problem is it's mis-parameterized
right almost like inject long-term
incentives into the capitalist system
exactly and
cryptocurrency space is the only
economic system where that's actually
possible
you can create a tokenomics scheme where
doing things that are beneficial for
people you'll never meet
because you're long dead actually makes
you money today
you can't do that in a legacy financial
system and so forth so i think that
that's the real impact capital
conversation that has to be had
as you explore these things is you have
to talk to people and say look it's not
about
communism or socialism versus capitalism
it's not about
hey let's donate and save the world or
try to be
charity and make things better it's all
about how do you use the fact that we
have a better toolkit
to create a different system a different
incentive model
where the default configuration of the
system is long-term thinking
and the default consideration the system
is to get rid of all these negative
externalities that marketplaces have
and judge the success of society not by
how the greatest of society are doing
but by how the least of society are
doing you know hdi not gdp
this kind of thinking and i think crypto
can actually be the the vanguard that
kind of pushes us there and the first
countries to adopt that
are going to be just significantly
better places to live
and so people who envy them will force
the other countries that's right
it'll be a ripple effect so when you
wake up in the morning or as you sleep
like a baby wake up multiple times in
the middle of the night
are you uh do you feel the burden
of of this kind of future that's in your
hands
and not to mess it up like what is it
big lebowski
her life is in your hands dude
don't worry about them they're nihilists
[Laughter]
do you do you feel the burden of like
because we were talking about all these
you know 100 plus papers and
the academic beauty of the algorithms
we're talking about but then there's
millions of human lives at stake here
i mean you always feel the burden
especially my own company i mean i have
all these people work for me and
you know they eat because i pay them
right so if i can't pay them then
that's my fault yeah so so you you you
have to
as a leader you always have to be
cognizant that there's all these people
have signed up for your crazy vision
and you have to be larger than life you
know you always have to be good
you you don't you're not allowed to have
a bad day you know you're not allowed to
feel like you always have to show
up you always have to be pushing forward
um and so that's a huge burden in many
respects because
there's charles the person and then you
know charles the ceo and these are very
different things uh in terms of
expectations at the very least
and so it's it's heavy in that respect
that said what gives you solace
is that you're not in it alone you know
it's lonely but you're not alone
you have so many amazing people around
you that are willing to help and
actually take some of that burden and
my life has gotten considerably better
when i learned how to delegate
and trust and even if people screw up
and fail
it's worth the risk because ultimately
you're amplifying yourself
the other thing is that it's okay not to
get all the way
you want to you want to push there but
make sure whatever the hell you do you
leave something for somebody else to
pick up and carry on
that's why we care so much about the
publication process and open source code
we'll never file a patent
in our entire history because whatever
we do it's yours as much as it is mine
and maybe i can only get you 70 percent
of the way and i'll plop over dead from
a heart attack or get killed by an eagle
or something like that
maybe somebody brings the angle maybe
somebody brings the hassed eagle back
and it kills me you know so
it could happen they're bringing the
woolly mammoth back talking to george
church about that
um it's a good way to go yeah the igor
or the mammoth
i'd rather be crushed by a mammoth
because eagles actually fly you up and
drop you
it's oh so you won't die you'll be a
slow death and they probably peck at you
exactly you just be grievously wounded
on the ground and the eagles like slowly
devouring you
yeah don't don't go down that way i've
lost my train of thought
the point is that you feel deeply great
there's a bunch of people around
you and then you give uh yeah you
delegate you delegate
and uh somebody fights the eagle and
other people takes care of that and this
that and the other you just do the best
you can you're in the arena you fight as
hard as you can
you leave nothing uh uh uh is for home
you could put it all on the field
and then when you go home you have pride
in what you've done and you know that
you've at least made a slight difference
you know one person can make a huge
difference look at norman borland
i mean just wonder our whole world
teaching people how to grow crops he
saved a billion lives over the course of
his life billion people didn't starve to
death because of one guy
it's amazing the asymmetry and the
returns on that type of thing just for
the knowledge transfer
of all things and yet not a household
name so that's the other side of it
of the burdens you know people always
want something
for something so they say oh if i
endured all these burdens i should be
given something
i entered into this space fully
expecting that probably the most likely
outcome was jail
that's what my dad told me and other
people told me and it was because it's
like look at where we came from the
liberty dollar
eagle all these things anybody tries to
innovate the monetary system
they either end up like gaddafi or they
end up in prison or
they end up you know like nepotis to
corrupt banker or something like that
and so you know the financial
regulations are not built for rapid
innovation they're not built for bitcoin
there's a reason satoshi was anonymous
it wasn't because you know he enjoyed it
because there was legitimate criminal
risk for this type of activity
so the fact that i've gotten this far
and i'm doing pretty good
that's a win you know you take that life
is good
you